breaking news adam and eve has sponsored
this show we
love adam and eve we love sex toys we
love
we love not having to put fingers in
ourselves
yeah we love we talked about the hate
fingers anyways adam and eve's number
one trusted story source for adult toys
visit adamandeve.com and use code mood
for 50
off one item and free shipping in the us
and canada some exclusions apply
again that's visit adamandeve.com and
use code
mood for 50 off one item and free
shipping in the us and canada
thank you adam and eve
hello welcome back to big mood it's a
big
time mood in here because we've been
doing so many things
um we've been all living our separate
lives recently and
just like doing extra extracurricular
activities
on our own we haven't been hanging out
as a group as much yeah and so
mostly because of social distancing
right yeah like we record a bunch of
episodes at once and then we kind of
don't see each other for a few weeks to
make sure if anyone's sick
yeah that you're quarantined but yeah
none of us have gotten sick yet but
i just think it's interesting because
like the only time i i consider you guys
like my closest friends
but the only time i actually talk to you
is like through the text
like the text chat that's what i'm like
i'm a low-maintenance friend yeah
so what have you been up to oh like real
life irl i've been
playing games and napping i'm not gonna
lie to you like for the last couple
weeks i've been kind of
this is kind of shitty like just
retweeted something yesterday that
i really really felt we've been in
quarantine for so long that we
got into shape and then back out of
shape again
during june may and june i lost a [ __ ]
ton of weight i was a skinny [ __ ]
queen
yeah and then now i'm starting to gain
weight back again and i'm like well i
never tried so i'm in the same spot i
think i'm on the
i'm i'm back into the losing weight yeah
i'm over the hump you did the opposite
of me
so like i was losing a [ __ ] ton of
weight and then you gained some no i
yeah we're like going the opposite oh
right i'm gaining weight and you're
losing well i was losing weight at the
beginning
and everyone and i wasn't trying i was
just like oh [ __ ] i'm just a skinny
[ __ ] without trying oh my god
and i didn't even know until my clothes
were like fitting looser and i was like
i don't even know what i'm doing i'm
eating oreos and [ __ ] yeah and then i
think those oreos caught up too because
yeah that's the boat i'm in now and then
i'm catching up to me my pants are
getting tight again
then i started exercising again just
recently within the past two weeks and
i'm like okay
one i did one yoga video class thingy at
home
and i made isaac do it with me and then
casey actually all three of us were
doing it
cute and that was like the first time we
ever did anything like a class like a
yoga thing
together as a family and that was i
guess it was terrible because you never
did it again
well oh i mean it was not actually
fully enjoyable because of the fact that
i messed up and i got
a intermediate level kind of yoga oh no
so
isaac could not keep up and he just
totally did not have fun and he was just
like i can't do this and i'm like just
relax just breathe it's supposed to be
like you know just
listen to your body but he was like
straining himself like really hard and
i'm like okay i feel like i should be
like a kid's
yoga first i feel like he's like you
though where he like wants to do it the
right way
yeah he's kind of a perfectionist so if
he can't do exactly what the person is
doing he's just frustrated that's
that's yeah it's my child it took yeah
like six months to figure out yoga
because before then i was like with
personal trainers it's very like
you know your form and everything it's
just like it's rigid right but then
you yoga is about like breathing into
the muscles
and i didn't get that i thought you just
had to like get there just go
do it just do as best you can you don't
have to put your feet over your ankles
and legs and
shoulders yeah just do this it's a
practice not a perfect
yeah so that's what happened like in may
and june i was working out you [ __ ]
saw
yeah yeah i was impressed super
impressed during our zoom meeting yeah
i didn't know she could even move her
body well me too crazy and then
and i was like [ __ ] yeah man like by the
time quarantine's over i'm gonna look
bomb and then they announce it's longer
and then i lost all motivation i think i
think that's what happened to me too i
was like oh skinny [ __ ] queen i'm
gonna look good for
anything that happens now the world's
opening back up i'm gonna go find me a
man
yeah and then they're like oh no this
[ __ ] is not going away so i was like all
right [ __ ] it i'm just getting fat
tell you what happened to me animal
crossing yeah yeah and
destroyed me so i lost like 20 pounds
and then i gained five now and i'm just
like you [ __ ] fat sack of [ __ ] you
still lost 15. you're still in debt i
still lost 15. that's nice
um so there's that and then lately i've
been
uh i i think it's becoming a problem
what
uh my name is gina and i'm addicted to
tick-tock yeah oh [ __ ]
it's getting bad but the thing is i'm
starting to grow it more so i can make
money off of it well that's good
and like have another big social media
platform so it's gonna get delayed
soon huh it's gonna get banned i thought
it was gonna get better i don't know i'm
still gonna leverage that
yeah what do you think about reels about
reels yeah it's great because i
am uh a partner and i'm doing facebook
facebook
is the worst man but the reals are great
have you been getting sponsorships on
your tick tock
how are you growing i think i grew by
like 10 000 this past night yeah because
i started collaborating with people and
it's just fun
because you know what it is i miss doing
the skits and stuff on youtube
and now it's just like we're all getting
together and just filming little skits
and it's
just those old days it was so
collaborative back then that's what i do
like about new platforms coming out is
that everyone gets back in that
collaborative spirit because nobody's
making money
with it everybody's just having fun and
then once it turns into a business where
people are making fun tons of money
that's when people get egos involved and
they get all cocky they don't want to
collaborate with you anymore true wait
but we have to talk about that amazing
hair
yeah our hair looks so good yeah my hair
done
dude i realized i haven't seen my hair
stylist since before my birthday
last year wow i got it done for my
birthday you had like seven or eight
inches of growth
my roots were all the way down to here
dang your hair grows fast
dude i haven't touched my hair i almost
did i had like i haven't touched my hair
in more than a year
yeah yours is kind of like that too
that's a lot of regrowth yeah
yeah so she finally ombre now like more
than a year i tell people that too it's
just an ombre
yeah no i actually did get an ombre oh
okay i was never up to my route
it was like around oh so you didn't have
that much growth
huh well yeah that's what i'm saying
like my hair does not grow as fast as it
used to because it's from like around
here to wherever it's at now yeah that's
how much
more than a year i think since the last
time i did anything but your hair looks
amazing
thank you i like the pencil i never
heard i never saw that oh
there's like a surprise there's stuff in
it so the other color
so it's like silver because i wanted
like party in the front i mean
this is in front of the back yeah so i
got like color in the back
it's purple and blue it reminds me of a
unicorn with the tinsel in there and
front is great what do you call that
gray or lavender gray lavender gray yeah
so i hit her up well another girl hit me
up to do my hair she's like hey i really
want to collaborate and do
your hair i'm like yeah sure it's fine
and then she got covered
oh no oh jesus yeah so i'm like oh no
never mind and then my hair stylist was
like hey i do like house calls now so
this took nine hours no i went over to
her house oh yeah so this took nine
hours because they gotta lift the dark
color
out of your hair that's why i haven't
gotten well that's not why but like i
haven't gotten mine done mostly because
i want to do cool colors but it would
take so much to
lift i would never imagine that with you
yeah well i was always like once i get
myself
once i get gray hair and i got my first
gray hair like a few weeks ago like
a month or two how are you older than me
and i have like a thousand gray hairs
i don't know jess i'm mad are you better
than just i don't have good ideas i'm
the eldest i don't have
veggies probably the filipino yeah
asian don't raisin yeah yeah so this is
my first um
like i'm do i'm trying to self-care as
much as i can i did my nails
nice because i've been in a slump yeah
in a weird way because it's like i'm so
sick of covid
and like on some days i'm great and on
some days i'm like i'm just gonna sit
around watch tv talks for 12 hours yeah
basically
yeah i was just telling tiff before the
um before we started the podcast um that
i've been i just coming out of a slump
of like a month or two where i just felt
ugly you ever just like
you wake up you look in the mirror and
you're just like no dude every day for
the past
like month or two i felt the ugliest i
have in a long time it's so so
weird because i wasn't feeling like that
in like may june yeah yeah
earlier in the year i wasn't feeling
that way it was mental illnesses it's
mentally ill we have to say that every
year
illness dude that's funny because for me
and it's gonna be a
oh sad tiff moment i'm not trying to do
that i'm not trying to do that
but for me it was my my whole life i
always would
be like that in front of a mirror like
no this isn't working ew what the [ __ ]
practically my whole life but um like
this past year and i don't think it was
quarantined or anything i think it's
more like the self work i've been doing
but now i look in the mirror i'm like oh
my god you're gorgeous
hell yeah i love it yeah i finally
figured that out i have like
zero makeup and i'm like how did i never
see this before oh my god i'm
glowing dude it's crazy you're making
people out there sad because
like i've always thought you were so
pretty yeah yeah yeah
yeah like without trying pretty i'm like
god damn it this girl
i would murder so many orphans for your
life
unnecessary could keep them alive and
you could have eyelashes parents are
going to miss them
she's great she has great eyebrows too
i've gone down a really dark path this
past few months however
uh light at the end of the tunnel i
don't know if any of you guys are
investing in stocks but
it's been a good month for me at least
for certain
stocks yeah shout out to tesla amazon
and apple
thank you you're making mama some money
wow i know i've been hearing a lot of
people get into stocks
recently and i'm like is this what i
should be doing next i'm growing up
i have nothing well right now they're
kind of those two
are like i don't i wouldn't buy right
now because they're like up like yeah
you have to wait till they hit like a
down time uh but i bought a couple
before the at the start of quarantine
when everything was crashing
and i i'm up like 80 percent
that's amazing i'm like i wish i put
more in uh yeah i'm only up like 22
but eighty percent is [ __ ] amazing
paypal man
yeah paypal because paypal
they always charge me 25.50
why so much i don't like whenever i get
like a brand deal or something and they
try to send it through paypal they just
charge a
[ __ ] ton i'm like no don't use paypal oh
damn i put that out i put that in my
contract you guys have to cover all fees
yeah yeah so that's what i'm gonna have
to do now paypal acquired venmo
the real reason i jumped into it yeah
the real reason i jumped in was well
that but then also um
because they they were one of the few
companies to get approved to give small
business loans during
the pandemic yeah because they're taking
all my goddamn money
thank you thank you for that money i'm
actually taking a seminar
um in a few weeks it's a digital seminar
like a zoom one usually the guy does it
in person it's like a workshop it's like
a weekend workshop
um but it's the guy that i've been
following forever that does warren
buffett strategies and he like breaks it
down into layman's terms and
and like how what's his name like find
companies long term
his name is phil towne and he does a
book he wrote a book called rule number
one
and a couple other books too but i
really got into him with rule number one
and it was the year it came out
which was 2006 and that's when i got
into
stock investing and bam i tripled my
money in a month
wow yeah using his strategies but then
when i tried to revisit the book
recently
a lot of how he breaks it down was
during the technologies back in 2006.
yeah and so like i don't know where to
find those same tools
now they're all completely like redone
and like completely different
and so i went by his baseline strategies
but i couldn't find
the exact tools that he uses so i want
to take his seminar again you walk out
like with a
whole portfolio afterwards of like
companies that resonate with you
and like using his metrics
hey we haven't done our master class
stuff together i know
i wanted to prove um casey wrong because
casey was like uh yeah i tried that and
i did like one or two classes that i
forgot about it yeah and i was like well
not me
i love learning i totally forgot i get
distracted by other things that i'm
learning and then i forget
no i i was distracted for a long time
with just animal crossing and i blame
you too
and then you abandoned me you both
abandoned me i don't know
both abandoned me but now ever since i
did the video just like you
ever since i did the the youtube the
what is it my island tour yeah
i haven't been playing either yeah it's
like a death video like once you show
off your island you're done with it
yeah and then it it's kind of messed up
because then now i've kind of abandoned
my mom because i got her into the game
and now she's just like fully into it so
she's like
mika are you gonna be playing today my
tournaments are good prices right now
you know michael i'm sorry well it's
kind of like payback for your childhood
oh no oh it's dark this episode
there's an eclipse man the light has
been shattered if you want
i don't know i don't know we'll see but
she's not wrong
i took a very spicy turmeric shot right
before this and i feel it coming back up
oh no
i was gonna say are you really gonna
throw up right now you talked about
murdering orphans you just
piped down this is true that's true
damn wait that's that's pretty much my
like
i was addicted that was my identity so
what have you been doing now
well now i've been more into i don't
know i've actually been
actively trying to stay away from animal
crossing to try to face
yeah so i've been trying to actively
stay away so i'm trying to find out
other things i can do
it's mainly around the house because our
backyard is practically done so right
now i
am i'm on the phase of like dressing it
up and making it look
nice because the whole construction part
was done and so now i've just been
building furniture
and like we have the same life path
because we do actually have the same
number the numerology number oh but um
and we're also
synced menstrual cycles yes but i was
not being best friends i mean there's a
whole couch around here
you can't sit with us just you know what
me and well yeah we're
just the same too we we like the same
music
yeah i like to watch her when she when
she
like strings up bugs and watches them
fly around oh yeah
that sounds like a cool club guys yeah i
wish i could join
yeah but this is a cool couch yeah [ __ ]
you guys
after the animal crossing addiction i
was like i'm a fat ass i gotta work out
again so i started working out
and then i got back into home decor like
i was doing before
so i had all this home [ __ ] that i
ordered and it was just so happy
finally did it every time i went to her
house i saw the box the same boxes there
everywhere get your [ __ ] life
together get the [ __ ] out of the box
addicted to animal crossing i gotta i
gotta play this game man not right now
man
you the turnips i'm don't understand
sell them
wait so what did you end up doing um so
yeah my bathroom
it's coming along it's like the longest
remodel i've ever done because of how
long
it took what are you laughing about in
your club
they're trying to make us feel left out
you know gina took a tumeric
shot before we started she threw up on
herself what happened
tommy just growled oh so loud
i'm sitting over here all i can hear is
[Laughter]
you're gonna take a massive [ __ ] soon i
like to think your stomach heard
bathroom remodel and it was like
oh you gotta go
yeah i don't recommend a bathroom
remodel it's just [ __ ] annoying
it's like you gotta if you wanna paint
you gotta go around the toilet and it's
so gross
all these crevices i'm just like this is
annoying i try to take the towel rack
bar off
that [ __ ] is nuts like there's anchors
holding it up it was like connected to
something deep into the wall
i'm like i should have never touched
this [ __ ] i should have picked the other
rooms
but they painted it such an ugly color
bad color but i'm like i have to paint
it
so i painted that um i also have i
ordered a bunch of like new
shelves and stuff to go in there um i
gotta i installed the light in the
shower
i installed new lighting above the
mirror and then i painted there's this
like
red entrance to our bedroom it's like a
they painted it this bright ass tomato
red
i don't know what this kind of crack
these people were smoking
that lived in our house early 2000s
crack yeah everyone used those
colors same red color palette yes
everyone had that true i did paint my
kitchen that back in the day
um but uh yeah so it and
originally our bedroom was green so it
was like bright tomato red into
green christmas wow what the hell
yeah it matched you because your last
names you know green's room
so i painted all that [ __ ] because green
walls are haunted man you can't you
can't have green walls in your house
handy people are so amazing to me like
you too you know what i did
that was like i'm very proud of you got
a
comforter
i got that and then i got uh i got two
alexa light bulbs oh [ __ ] and i set it
up
so it's stupid in my room now so when i
say alexa's sexy time my lights go red
and marvin gaye comes on
or like i say alexa i'm sad and then my
lights go blue and celine dion's my
heart will go on comes on it's time
yeah come over and do the tech on my
house and i'll go over and do
we could do a trading spaces oh my god
that is so cute all the time when i was
a kid
you check out me and uh tiff's house and
we'll go and redecorate your room
yeah that's a joke yeah so fun you're
really fun
uh i i got into yu-gi-oh i don't know
you guys probably don't give a [ __ ]
about that i started playing what'd you
call it card games
how do you play that it's a battle game
i don't even want to get into it but for
you nerds out there i got into yugioh
what's up hit me up i heard those cards
are worth lots of money dude that's all
i know about it i know someone with
their whole collection's like worth at
least fifty thousand dollars damn
yeah that's what steve was telling me he
was like yo i was making fun of it and
then this guy told me his was worth like
thirty thousand dollars i was like oh
[ __ ] you gotta check out these yukio
cards
i went with one you have a husband
that's into you again i got a bunch of
yugioh cards
my my friend like he's like hey i'm
buying this yu-gi-oh card off this guy
it's like a mint condition one can you
come with me because they met
on like instagram and it was like it was
like a sketchy drug deal
he brought you along for a sketchy
yu-gi-oh card exchange that is
the least trade the least sketchiest
trade i've ever done so it's okay
i would feel safe bringing gina cause
she has she she can protect me yeah
so like he bought the card for 1700
bucks and now it's worth 6 thousand and
i'm just like what the like this is
better than the stock market yeah
how do you find out the new prices um
whatever is on this mark i don't even
know nerd foreign
said it i bet because like the beanie
babies were like that i got all kinds of
beanie babies with ty tags guess what
now they're worthless
i know you have no idea my aunt was
so into beanie babies she had like an
entire garage full of them like it was
ridiculous and it's crazy because at
that time if you walked into someone's
house like that you're like oh
[ __ ] this is crazy this is so cool and
now you're like
remember when people would have like you
know the back seat of your car like
where the weight is
people would just stuff like 50 of them
back there and i'm like wow this is
white traveling my mom still hasn't
taken the tags off of them i saw my
little nephew playing with one of my old
beanie babies and it still has a tag on
it i'm like you can take this [ __ ] out
now
the tag protectors the little yeah the
plastic ones
i forgot about that ooh and i remember
seeing a picture of this
couple getting a divorce in court and
they were separating
my baby the judge is like this is what i
went to school for
i only kept one out of my like
crazy ass collection i only kept one and
it's the it's this red
beanie baby and it's like the bigger
ones not the standard middle sizes like
the bigger ones
it's all red and it has mexico flag how
cute
and i don't want you to because that's
where i was born and raised you have to
remember that yeah
she's bilingual and [ __ ]
i had the princess diana one oh i had
that one too oh my god listen it's
purple right when that came out
in uh i think it was like 2014-ish 15
they were saying that if you had that
purple one the princess diana
beanie baby that it was worth like an
insane amount of money
and i was looking everywhere in my house
because i actually had kept two beady
babies i didn't mention the other one
because
i ended up losing it and i realized i
lost it when i was trying to find it for
that like around that time
and then i find out that it's only if
you bought it in the uk
uk specific diana beanie beanie baby
so the reason why the purple mattress is
amazing is because they have the purple
grid
which sets the purple mattress apart
from every other mattress
it's a patented comfort technology that
instantly adapts to your body's natural
shape and sleep style
it's pretty cool because it's like gummy
and it's shaped like like a honeycomb
kind of
shape and it just really is really
comfortable
and so with over 1 800 open air channels
designed to neutralize body heat
purple provides a cooling effect other
mattresses can't
replicate and this cutting edge
technology
doesn't stop with the mattress every
purple pillow is engineered with a grid
for total head and neck support and
absolute air flow so you'll always
be on the cool side of the pillow so you
can try
every purple product risk free with free
shipping and returns and purple has
financing available as low as zero
percent apr for qualified customers
so experience the purple grid and you'll
sleep like never before go to purple.com
big mood 10 and use promo code big mood
10 for a limited time you'll get 10
off any order of 200 or more that's
purple.com
big big mood 10. promo code big mutant
for 10
off any order of 200 or more terms apply
that's amazing you know what else you
can do in that purple mattress what eat
food like a big piece of [ __ ]
yeah and with doordash you barely have
to move you barely have to do anything
at all
you get food delivered right to your
door obviously it's in the name doordash
you only have to walk up to the door yes
that's all you have to do or
i don't know maybe you don't maybe you
can get your kid or someone to go get
your food
continue supporting the restaurants in
your local neighborhood they need your
help
obviously they're not getting as much
patronage as they used to
so support the support the restaurants
that you love
doordash will bring you anything that
you're craving right now ordering is
easy open the doordash app choose what
you want to eat the food will be left
safely outside your door with their new
contact list delivery drop off setting
you can support your local go-to's or
choose from also national
favorite restaurants like chipotle
wendy's and the cheesecake factory
right now our listeners can get five
dollars off and zero delivery fees on
their first order
of fifteen dollars or more download the
doordash app and enter code big
mood that's five dollars off and zero
delivery fees on your first order when
you download the doordash app in the app
store and enter code
don't forget one more time that's called
big mood for five dollars off your first
order with doordash
yay i love using our codes when i
i know i use all of our codes right
everything i feel like a drug dealer
dipping into my own stash
they don't know it's me
how about you jesse yeah jess gina
jesus i want to be part of the club
it looks like you did your hair today by
the way so oh it's super dirty this is
yours i use my hair when i haven't
washed it in several days
it's very tanya harding of you what
oh white trash i guess i was just like
a figure skater oh it's not the one that
i heard her
her knees got no she's the one that
voiced oh she got
oh she did she hired some people to do
that i just remember margot robbie
played her
i love margot yeah you're looking very
margo robbie wish
thank you for that um so me i
am getting ready to move uh into a new
apartment which i'm pretty excited about
because the
the apartment that i'm in right now i
just kind of had to rush into it
because you know i ended my relationship
and had to move out and it was a very
quick process
hey hey thanks yeah i still get dms and
people are like you know
[ __ ] steve and nikki broke again yeah
we did it yeah
no we created the bad toxicity
relationship
but yeah no so i had to rush into the
place i'm at now and i and it was fine
or whatever but my upstairs
neighbor is the worst [ __ ] upstairs
neighbor i've ever had i
hate this [ __ ] so they're good at being
upstairs neighbors basically
they're doing their job right i feel
like the biggest karen i've ever felt in
my life
because i've never sent so many
complaints to a front office
since i moved into this apartment
complex but this [ __ ] let me tell you
about this [ __ ]
she like when i first moved like
probably like springtime so i'd been
there for a few months the wintertime i
guess she never really went outside or
anything but when spring came
until now uh so she's been spending more
time on her balcony or whatever but
she would like be sweeping her balcony
and like all the dirt and [ __ ] would be
raining on top of my nose
it gets worse then one time i guess her
mom was up there with her or something
and they were doing more cleaning and i
guess they were
mopping or something but they dumped the
mop water
over the balcony so all this dirty mop
water yeah
you're cute as [ __ ] all my cute ass i
you you guys have seen my baby yeah i
laid down like a wood paneling yeah yeah
i made it super cute and then um on top
of that she has a cat and i guess the
cat goes out there maybe takes a [ __ ] or
something so when the wind blows
dried up cat [ __ ] will fall from her
balcony
so i walk outside to like dried up
pieces of cat [ __ ]
and then i saw she drops like a [ __ ]
just drops off of her balcony too so
like i've had trash like plastic forks
and knives and stuff
and then loose cigarettes and then one
day i went out there
and i found up like a piece of a bong
had like you know like the head the
thing that you pull out or whatever like
where the ball yeah yeah the
[ __ ] bowl yeah so anyway that had
rolled off of her balcony landed onto my
couch and then hit the floor and i'm
like this
[ __ ] can't keep her [ __ ] in her own
square feet
how can how can you not know that your
[ __ ] is falling onto someone else's
bathroom no
even art supplies too so she's probably
a [ __ ] hippy white trash
[ __ ]
she can't keep her [ __ ] in her own
balcony she spoke from her chest
i told you jess every every night at
like three a.m just vacuum your ceiling
oh and then when she has her boyfriend
over and they have sex out
the other day i was laying in my bedroom
and like because when her man is over
there like he
he his feet are really heavy oh he walks
the heel he walks with the heel
like all men do which is super annoying
i'm like it's three in the morning walk
on the balls of your feet like a gentle
person right have some dudes i'm like
yeah so anyway they were having sex the
other night and i was just laying there
right here
and i'm just staring at my ceiling and
i'm like i wish i had a shotgun i would
shoot it through the [ __ ] ceiling
do you play music or anything to try to
drown her out i had the ac going right
which is kind of loud i had a noise
machine going i had earplugs in
and i was playing the office on the tv
well that's a lot like so i had all of
this [ __ ] on and i
still hear like and then
i'm like get me out of here so anyways i
found a cute apartment on the west side
are you on the top floor no okay so i'm
on the fourth floor but this i i decided
to spend a little bit more money
because i'm like maybe these people will
be quieter or it's like older or more
respectful or something because like the
apartment i'm in right now is kind of
cheap so i feel like
a lot of young people a lot of young
people live there it's like a very
ecology
type of place so that's why i'm like
just trying to
get away from all that but yeah this
one's on the west side by the beach and
i can't
wait i can't wait to visit you yeah it's
gonna be awesome and so because i i have
like a few weeks left by the time this
comes out i'll probably have already
moved but
i'm going to kill some time and drive to
texas
oh what are you doing what are you
driving with yeah what are you driving
driving what are you what are you doing
i'm just driving a car
what kind of car i mean the car that i
have that's all that's how old is that
how old is this new car that you got i
mean how old is this car you got
okay well um i got a car
and i am now a part of the the uh
[ __ ] beemer club
i i am i am i've turned into what i hate
which is like an
uppity white person long enough to
become the villain
yeah yeah so i priced myself out of the
college dorm room apartment that i was
in before now and i got it i upgraded my
car
i hope you only wear dark gucci's
everywhere yeah absolutely
absolutely it comes it comes with the
beamer right yeah
i only i only call it a beamer i don't
see bmw
a beamy yeah i'm gonna join like
all the [ __ ] bmw forums and [ __ ] and
just turn into the biggest [ __ ] can
you can you get the mom like diamond
encrusted license plate
you'll be a true karen yeah yeah
everyone will know that she has a carrot
i'm just gonna get the license plate
that says karen oh god yeah
congratulations i know that's so
exciting yeah yeah so you're gonna go
visit yourself yes
i'm gonna go drive my 500 horsepowers to
texas
and burn a [ __ ] ton of gas in the
process
um no i'm just filling the gas tank with
money just burn it all
yeah but no um yeah so i well because of
kovid
i stopped going to the gym i had a 200
[ __ ] equinox membership and i was
paying for a trainer so all that money
is now
in my car i'm pretty happy about it yeah
good investment
yeah yeah well it's not really an
investment because i just leave i mean
investment in yourself yeah investment
in my
thing yes uh feeling more like a douchey
[ __ ]
just makes me feel a little bit better
yeah inside for sure it fills the hole
it levels up yourself it does normal
level fills the hole to a normal level
yeah
so like you could be crying like you
could be sad at least you're crying in a
bmw i am yeah
a beamer yeah i cry on my beamer um i am
no longer are we allowed to call it that
you know
it's kind of like it's kind of uh not
that good of a look if you don't own it
and i'm sticking to it yeah it's a bmw a
beat me yeah
i drive a handy honey nice
i wasn't alexi before oh that's cute
yeah but no uh so i got a really good
deal i actually i
i found a um a car broker and he got
this dude i've been fighting with bmw
people for like a week straight like i
did all this research i was like i know
what the thing should be i know what the
money factor should be
i know what the residual value should be
i know what my [ __ ] monthly payment
should be and i know what my drive-off
fees are and i'm like fighting all of
these people to get this lease like the
best price and they're all like no
that's not possible
so then i've got this car broker and
just in less than 24 hours he got the
deal that i wanted so i'm like
nice i'm kind of pissed because i'm like
you don't respect women exactly i don't
respect exactly
i respect a man but anyways speaking of
that i get so
peeved when uh so i am like the first
signer or whatever in our house in the
car um
you're the responsible financial
individual so i'm
i'm pretty much like the head of
household and when it comes to all these
things but
every time they're sending oh like
recently i got a ticket
for you like the fast track thing my
little transponder didn't work
i gotta pay my tickets you gotta pay a
girl
but if you link it to a transponder why
people don't respect
[ __ ] well anyway so i got that ticket
right
they had they addressed it to casey and
i'm like
good for you i'm like [ __ ] you i'm the
fir
it's my car like i'm the first signer
like why is kate my name wasn't even on
there
i'm like that doesn't even make sense is
he even on on it well he's a co-signer
like a co-owner or whatever but but
usually like you know
whatever yeah you guys are married to me
too my dad co-signed and they only
address it to him and i'm like
hello i pay all the bills here it's so
insulting and then even for our house
too like i was the first signer
on the deed or whatever but then like
they'll address the
mail to casey and i'm like what the [ __ ]
see
they had to only use my stuff on when we
purchased this house so i'm actually
the sole owner oh of it um and it drives
steve's crazy so
i like to bring it up all the time i saw
that when as soon as you say anything
about credit or something steve just
[ __ ]
like steam comes out oh yeah yeah i
break it up all the time i would give
him [ __ ] all the time just any time
you're in my house you used to abide by
my rules don't be cutting
your [ __ ] limes on my counter
oh that's so toxic
i love it i will pick on him all the
time
can i come over to your house later your
house yeah my house your house
you can come over to my house i don't
have to ask anyone yeah that's my house
um but yeah uh on the uh i remember on
our when we
uh got married and we had to join our
checking account um
on the checks they put his name first
and
i was just like i'm gonna say that's
reversed
i'm the one managing the finances dude
you know what else too it got it really
irked me too because
when we went i forgot where we went but
i was the one
asking the questions i was the one
inquiring about this thing
oh i think it was when we were meeting
with landscapers so we were meeting with
landscapers and i was the one like
leading
the meeting because your landscapers
were mexican usually exactly
so i was thinking you know
over here oh jesus christ nikki oh my
god just with an accent poor
and concrete stupid no but yeah so then
like i would speak or the ones that
didn't speak spanish because you're
right i mean they did speak spanish i
speak spanish to them but the ones that
didn't speak spanish
they would i would ask him a question
and he looked at casey and
answer oh i'm like that you [ __ ] kid
but did you call him out um well i
started getting a little [ __ ] because
i'm like
oh yeah you know how i asked that
question and then i'm like you know how
i was the one who was asking like
i don't it's just next time it happens
next time tiff look him in the face and
said i asked you that question so you
can answer me
yeah yeah it happened when we were
searching for wedding venues
i would ask all the questions and the
person in charge of the wedding venue
would just
respond to steve i'm like you know
what's really funny too and i just
i it was like my own personal enjoyment
entertainment because
they would be talking to kate like i'll
ask the question they'll respond to
casey
and in case he's so [ __ ] lost he's
like
what what oh yeah and then he'll ask a
question
that they had just answered but then
he's the one asking it because now he
feels like oh should i need to be
engaged in this conversation because now
they're addressing it to me
and then the person gets frustrated
because they were like didn't i just
answered that and i'm like that's what
you get for talking to him
yeah we see that dumb ass i'm working
with that's how i feel when i go to
gamestop to buy video games like oh
you're getting it for your boyfriend i'm
just like
[ __ ] i will kill you in the back right
now i swear to god
i'll kill you i'll kill you address me
one time we went into
brookstone and i was trying out the
massage chair and i was seriously
considering i was like you know what i
just got a fat brand deal check i want
to
get one of these five thousand dollar
massage chairs wow oh yeah
i have there were two thousand they're
five thousand dollars well the one out
the model
i was looking at huge top of the line
the modern model okay the beamer model
exactly
um i have a [ __ ] up back i don't know
if you could if i've talked about that
before
i have scoliosis i have and i keep all
my stress there and like
yeah it's just always messed up so i go
to a
masseuse well i try to go once a month
but in the
inner rim it gets all [ __ ] up and so i
was like maybe if i had a massage chair
like that would really
help with things um and i was testing
them out
and the sales guy steve's not even in
the chair but he's just talking to steve
the whole time about the selling points
and all the stuff
and like the how they have finance plans
and different payment plans and stuff
i'm like
[ __ ] i i don't want this chair yeah i'm
out of this chair you could have had a
chair
sale right now mister you know what i
actually really like which could be seen
as
as a hypocritical i guess but
what i really enjoy is when we used to
back in the day when we used to go to
restaurants and we could sit inside and
like have a waitress and stuff
i loved it when the waitress would
address me directly like and try to
maintain eye contact with me even though
casey was talking to her
i mean yes talking to her but i don't
know i mean it is hypocritical but i
liked getting the attention and it made
me feel like
nice like she respects me she knows like
you know i'm i'm his
woman or whatever and like she's not
trying to like flirt to get more tip if
anything she's playing her cards right
because now i'm going to tip more
because she's giving me the attention
when i worked at hooters if the guy came
in with his girlfriend i would pretty
much just only talk to her yeah and
when you set the check down i would
always put it in the middle of the table
i hate when they just give it to the guy
immediately i'm like
that's rude first of all because what if
he's not in the position and what if
there's a first
date you don't even know yeah but yeah i
would always put it in the middle and
then when i bring it back i put it in
the middle of the table
just in case yeah that's how you should
do it exactly
respect man you know now with these
times i kind of wonder like what are the
the long-term effects of like the
service industry for example like are we
are we really gonna have yeah well
because you know like how starbucks was
talking about getting rid of like pretty
much a lot of their stores and just
being like kind of a pickup spot yeah
and like so i feel like a lot of
restaurants might be moving towards that
like
or outdoor patios versus indoor seating
like just knock the whole thing down
leave the kitchen
and make everything outdoors uh there
was a restaurant that i went to that
didn't have
menus anymore and said they'd have you
sign a qr co or
qr code on your desktop that brings up
the menu on your phone which was cool
that was really cool
that's really cool i've been cooking a
lot well i've seen yeah
i was like look at you being all wifey
people are so surprised actually
but wow it's more shocking to hear from
gina i know it's because i ain't got
[ __ ] to do like i've been really getting
getting in touch with like random
hobbies now yeah you know it's a cookie
that's dope gina gina did it right she
set the bar so low
that like if she does like domestic
tasks people like what
yeah you turned on an oven yeah i've
been telling people do you remember to
turn it off
a little bit like this
a little bit loopy today i've been
breathing in a lot of the a lot of the
fumes with
you know it's fine i've been telling you
guys set the bar low so anything that
you do people were like wow
yeah but yeah i've been cooking so much
i have like i've been doing like
at home full spread of like shopping
i've been watching your stories thanks
yeah and like korean barbecue like i've
been having a good time cooking
you know behind your habits is a
psychological reason you're doing those
things and noom can help you out with
that
um you know if you have specific goals
you want to achieve
you can you can figure those out it
doesn't just have to be physical
sometimes we don't realize that we have
habits that are
keeping us beneath our goals like um for
example i didn't realize i
just grabbed food when i have anxiety
like i just uh
i was just eating a bunch of snacks and
it was because i had a lot of anxiety
and then
you know when you dig into that
psychological aspect and really like
work on it
you realize oh [ __ ] i don't really have
to be i wasn't hungry i was just
eating cause cause i have stress i was
worried
yeah about the world and i thought that
was safety for some reason
um with noom there's ease and
convenience it's just 10 minutes a day
the tone of the program
works with your lifestyle you don't have
to commit to a rigorous plan
that's it's based in psychology to break
the bad habits it's based on cognitive
behavioral
approaches and uses personalized courses
to help you reach your specific goals
and over 80 percent of numerous finish
the program and over 60
have stuck with their goals for at least
one year how about that there's a
science to getting healthier it's called
noom
sign up for your trial today at noom
n-o-o-m-dot-com
big mood what do you have to lose visit
noom.com
big mood to start your trial today
that's noomnoom.com
big mood that's right
so another sponsor best fiends my
favorite
so best fiends is a mobile puzzle game
that has these really cute adorable
little characters and each character has
its own kind of power that helps you
unlock this puzzle
and so you have to defeat the slugs with
these fiends
and i have been playing this game for a
solid what five years i think
i have been playing this game for too
long i love this game because it's also
really cute how they have like the
the graphics because usually mobile
games at least the ones that i've come
across
they the graphics aren't that nice like
they don't really look
cute right they don't look good to look
at and so for best fiends though
it's really really adorable and also
it's an offline game so
every time i'd be traveling back in the
day when we used to travel in the
airplane i used to be playing
if you're in a basement sometimes like
in those places where they don't have
wi-fi oh yeah even in my new place yeah
sometimes there's there's like dead
zones
and that's when i get bored and i start
playing best fiends
and anyway so like i said these
characters
you can collect them all they also have
different themes every month
so they have different challenges there
you can never get bored with this game i
absolutely love it so best fiends has
thousands of levels already with new
levels events and characters added every
month
it's hours of fun right at your
fingertips and you can even play offline
like i mentioned
with over 100 million downloads and tons
of five star reviews best fiends is a
must play
download best fiends free on the apple
app
store or google play that's friends
without the r
best fiends what size shoes are you uh
like seven
what the hell is going on here yeah i
don't know so they do look small
oh cause yeah it's the shape of a round
paper it's so cute
i do not have small feet eight how about
you
six and a half years
speaking of small i just i'm fostering a
litter of kittens
not gonna be fostering yeah soon you're
gonna keep them you're keeping them
you're gonna
you're gonna be a seven cat lady they're
all gonna have babies and then you're
gonna keep all those babies and it's
gonna be a tornado in my dreams
jess and my dreams how did this come
about yeah
um well i always wanted to do it i don't
know if you guys do you know howard
stern the radio
show host okay so his wife beth stern um
who was also a model
yes um she was a supermodel she sorry
and then she's not just howard stern's
wife yeah well she
had an instagram and that i've been
following since like 2014.
and all she does is rescue kittens like
so she has like a whole lovely lady
that's wrestling oh yeah
that's dope like she has a whole level
of her penthouse that's just
kitten fosters and she would like keep
us updated throughout the day like on
each one and each one had their own
story
and she'd like be updating it and you
just get attached to you get attached
vicariously through her posts
and i was like man and and she also like
was a huge advocate for animal rights
and would like
post about different uh mistreatments
and stuff and like things and like
basically just keeping you up to date on
um on just animal stuff and and so i
really liked following her
and um and i was like man if i ever got
to the level
where i could just foster kittens i
would do it in a heartbeat so it was
always like once we buy a house
once we buy a house i'll dedicate a room
to like fostering kittens
and then we bought a house and i was
like i'm too busy
and so i was like busy busy busy and
then the pandemic happened
and i'm like well now's the time yeah
yeah
and i have this extra bonus room that we
had been trying to figure out what to do
with forever and i put a treadmill in
there and so it's kind of like an
exercise-ish room but
um you know it's really just sitting
there like there's not really anything
going on
there and so um i signed up and
uh i i was like okay i'm gonna take the
take the plunge for years i've been
going to their kitten fur ball they're
like
gala and like they're like when you got
a foster and so i finally
signed up and it's they said that it was
going to take a few months because
there's so many
foster parents sign ups because of the
pandemic so they're like everyone had
the same idea
yeah they're like you probably won't get
a batch for a while saying to me there's
like always
so many animals yeah you would see so
many
i know and so i don't know what like i
don't know why
they're yeah well anyway uh so i was
like okay i got like a few months i took
the orientation i'm like i got a few
months to like
kind of figure out how to prep this
space and like immediately
they were like hey [ __ ] there's a
lot of cats and dogs about home
yeah well like maybe they wanted to weed
people out that weren't
true super about it that might be true
because i did go directly to like
one of the higher-ups in the
organization like hey i'm ready and
she's like oh great good
um but i guess a lot of times the mom
with litters uh gets overlooked like
people don't want to deal with the mom
cat because they're just like kind of
scared or there might be the mom might
be overprotective you know so they don't
know or like sometimes they're feral
um but i was like yeah i'm in let's do
it and the mom is so
sweet she's like so trusting she's
sweeter than my boys right off the bat
my boys are like really skeptical about
people they're like i don't
you can't touch me i don't know you but
the mom was just like give me love and
attention
so the boys taking the new cats yeah at
first they were terrified which is
really funny seeing these big boy cats
be like
frightened of kittens they were like oh
my god and they wouldn't even look at
them
they didn't hiss or anything they just
like we have them separated with a glass
door so they can see the kittens the
kittens can see them
but they can't like contact each other
because you have to keep them isolated
so it's really perfect uh but i was like
oh my god it's gonna be so fun because
i'll just watch kittens all day
no they were in denial they refused to
even come down the stairs
to like eat their food because they were
pissed they were just like
we now we don't want to take your
knowledge dare you mom
and they got really needy too they like
they got jealous so cute
i got super jealous they needed to be
cuddling with me
constantly and and now it's to the point
we've had them for a week now um
they'll go down there and like check the
scene out and franklin likes to sniff
the window like because mama cat comes
right up to the window and they like
kiss each other through the window it's
pretty cute and like i always go is that
your girlfriend
you tease him lovely
how many kittens are there there's four
kittens okay what are their names
okay so we got kahlua she's brown she's
like
i did kahlua we got grey goose who goes
by gigi
uh i love that yeah we got
um guinness he's like really dark and
he's got like a white
foam face you guys are alcoholics yeah
exactly and then we got oh tom collins
who's that he's a great drink yeah oh
cause no but yeah
like i didn't know it was like what it
was yeah it's like an old-fashioned or
something
yeah yeah he's actually our favorite
he's the one that looks the most like
franklin
my my cat and he comes and runs and
greets you and he's only four weeks old
so he's the tiniest
the tiniest little cat do they have let
him meet him because i remember i had
cats when i was super super young and i
remember they
they would have like you'd have to do a
lot like when they were first born like
they would get worms and they would just
be yeah
like a whole thing there is yeah um so
i'm waiting for
they have to hit a certain um weak old
to get dewormed
and for their bodies to be able to
handle like medicine and stuff like that
so waiting for six weeks to get their
deworming
in uh they need two doses but they have
to be spread out
and then i have to weigh them every day
to make sure they're gaining weight
um because if not that could be a sign
of something internal
but the organization's really cool they
have like private medical coordinators
and distributors and veterinarians so
whenever they need to be tested or get
shots or whatever
when that time comes you can just go
directly to them and set up
no it's like they make it easier for the
foster yeah so there's kind of like no
reason why you couldn't
exactly yeah yeah and they're and
they're all volunteers too so
they're on call like 24 7. for emergency
situations and stuff
yeah but um it i it fills my heart
i'm like i can tell as soon as i saw
them on the story i was like oh she is
deep
yes but you know what's funny yeah steve
is more deep than me
[Applause]
this guy he's not going to let you get
rid of them he's like we're keeping them
all them
like we gotta get rid of them boo like
once they get older and bigger
then you might be like okay this is a
lot of cats it it will be a lot of fun
that's like four or five six seven cats
yes in one house what's wrong with that
jess that's too many
it's actually illegal in california i
think the max is five
or six six yeah that's already too many
yeah they let you keep them oh if you're
fostering that oh it's a temporary
situation
so you just constantly
[Laughter]
oh my god you [ __ ] planned that joke
i did it
she's a cat pedo okay
tone it down i do groom them but
oh jeez you're with your tongue i just
got it you grabbed again sorry
it's a little grooming um
get me out of this video what the [ __ ]
seriously what the hell listen guys
we're talking about cats
just chill the [ __ ] out okay [ __ ] but
okay
little baby [ __ ] now you want to join
me
[Applause]
[Laughter]
i just wanted to prove to the world that
you can be married and be a crazy cat
lady
not impossible seriously
yes you would when isaac flies the coop
oh yeah we're trying to make a new one
yeah she's like you better have a child
so you don't turn
i think that's what happened i've been
trying to have a baby that's not coming
fast enough so i got to get kittens
yeah i've been seriously contemplating
getting a second cat you should
i think he needs it i think he needs a
friend i'm a big fan of animals and
pears but the problem is i'm allergic to
cats and the only so i want to get
another bengal no because bengals are
hypothetical blinds have allergens i
have to get another bengal but then
[ __ ] are expensive as [ __ ] yeah you
don't ever spend money gina
i don't know you're just hoarding all
day at the same place where you got
nibbler my parents yeah they don't breed
anymore oh yeah
so i'm kind of contemplating getting him
a really like cute girlfriend
yeah like a silver bengal super hot yeah
you know
your cat's already been spayed or
neutered right i don't need babies i
just want him to have a friend to just
hang out with so
i think the mama cat is half bangle oh
really her markings look
really bangle but on top she looks tabby
but on the bottom she looks bengal
yeah so like because this kid for some
reason
is the most he's a [ __ ] bag um
he only wants to bother me and play
fetch
the moment i turn on my stream wow and
throughout the whole stream he's
screaming like cause he knows you're
gonna be busy yeah not paying attention
yeah he wants to be a gamer yeah so he
just screams at me and then my chat
starts cracking up because there's this
[ __ ] cat just yelling at me
or like what does that sound like cause
man like he sounds like he's saying
and then and then he's he learned this
new thing where he jumps from the back
of my seat onto the seat back oh yeah
shoulder and it scares the [ __ ] on me
every time because it's new
so and then the moment my stream is off
he's like oh [ __ ] i don't care anymore
wow
our cats are so similar yeah he's cuz
every time i'm talking if i'm on the
phone or if i'm talking to a person
he needs to be like right here children
are the same way guys
children are the same way exactly
exactly the same exactly
so that's why i feel like i need to get
them a girlfriend so they can [ __ ] off
together
while that while i'm working yeah or
they're both just gonna they're
screaming at you while you're on your
stream that's what happened to me
yeah i got two shadows now yeah but
it'll be fun it'd be it'd be cute to get
him a little girlfriend we'll see but
it's just that's a lot of [ __ ] money
those things run for like at least
fifteen hundred dollars each and yeah
geez my kids are actually really
independent they don't really
bug mine is too until i start streaming
until i have to do something important
for me it's when
whenever it's time to go to bed that's
when they jump on the bed yeah yeah and
then they're like cool it's time to for
a second
i'll go to sleep i love that though they
like know it's bedtime
they get all excited to go to bed no my
cat's just like all right so now's the
time i'm gonna bite the [ __ ] out of your
toes
oh no it's three in the morning and then
we go to bed
what do your dogs do my dogs yeah did i
bug you no well so uh my last
relationship
joe calling him out he got the dogs on
the bed
and he was like look they're so cute we
can cuddle them just please let them
sleep in the bed
so i never let my dog sleep in the bed
when i lived in texas before i moved out
here but then so he trained them to get
on the bed so now i've been
retraining them off the bed off the
couch you give them a take on good luck
yeah yeah took it away sorry guys but
for dogs there's kind of a dominance
issue
so it's just like i don't feel like it
was good for our relationship for them
to think that they're
in control of the household like because
then their behavior
is problematic and stuff so now i found
this thing on amazon
because uh when i leave my apartment i
leave my dogs in my bedroom because
if i let them just roam around the whole
apartment they'll be at the front door
you know
barking at whoever's walking by so i
leave them in the bedroom i like turn on
the noise machine and they're just like
more quiet and comfortable in the back
but now so maddie would always jump on
my bed and i found this thing on amazon
they make these
foil sheets oh yeah yeah yeah it's like
this huge foil sheet so i leave it on my
bed and so whenever she would try to
jump up there it would make sense
so many links have you seen the tick
tocks yeah oh i haven't seen that and i
had never seen this before i i just
found it
it works they have the cat ones where
they put it on the counters to keep the
cats from jumping up there
yeah it makes a lot of noise they like
jump up and i can't just like jump in
the air it freaks out yeah
please send me a link because i am done
with
one of my cats yeah yeah but if you let
them sleep there at night it's probably
going to confuse them because maddie oh
no the bed's okay oh okay no it's like
the countertops and
remember i've been complaining oh the
car about one of my cats
pooping on one of the couch yeah yeah he
had just covered the whole couch in the
foyer ever since we got these like uh
you know the acupressure
pads yeah the ones that have like like
they're really spiky
and like they're supposed to like you
lay down on them now you lay down on
them so we got two of those pads and we
covered the
specific corner of the couch that he
likes to take a [ __ ] on he hasn't [ __ ]
oh they they also they also make plastic
um like
sheets that have like spikes in them so
like nothing like
an animal can't like sit on the but i
don't know i know the foil ones work
really well because the noise is just so
jarring
so that's that's how i've been able to
train them take
well so they don't jump up there anymore
oh okay i think
um when i first got the foil sheet it's
you know obviously like a clean sheet of
foil or whatever
and then the first day i put it up there
there's like a couple of
my foot like like nail scratches in it
and ever since then i've never seen any
more so i think she saw and
and she tried it and it was so [ __ ]
loud and scary so funny she hasn't tried
it since it just has the day one nail
scratches that where she got up and
probably freaked out
so that reminds me of you like have you
ever seen those videos of like there's
like someone who baked a cake and you
see one paw print in it yeah
yeah [ __ ] bag or like there's a snow
right outside the door you see one paw
print they're like
yeah dude that's how my casper whenever
i was painting there'd just be
like blue paw prints i'm like god damn
it
that's adorable they always have to get
their noses and everything yeah
[ __ ] i love them you know what i
think it is uh with us we're all talking
about
our [ __ ] pets if you're in your 30s
and you haven't had kids yet or if your
kid's too grown
yeah mine's 12. you just like seek
things to take care of i have so many
plants and so many cats at my house
we're about to become plant people oh
yeah yeah because for our backyard oh
dude i need a hijab so for our backyard
we're gonna be having a whole bunch of
like pots and we actually want to
have live plants because all the plants
inside my house are all fake because the
cats dig into the dirt
and they like eat the leaves and stuff
so they can never keep any life
inside but for the outside for the
backyard and the front yard we're gonna
have a whole bunch of plants and
so i'm going to have you help me yes i
would love to
i have certain um for cova there's like
plant delivery services too
and they actually have i feel better
quality plants than when you go to like
the nursery or home depot because
they haven't been sitting like outside
getting off yeah i feel like
i try to buy stuff from uh home depot
like the old house that we had we we had
live plants in there and they would
always come with mites yeah like i don't
know how to figure out because it
doesn't look like it has it in the store
and then like a week later the house is
teaming with little fruit flies and like
yeah
so i that's the reason why i i'm not a
plant mom yet because i'm like [ __ ]
that i hate butter hook you up with my
sides i want you okay i need plants
and then i realize how [ __ ] expensive
it is it's really expensive let's just
go outside to the park and yank some out
of the ground and [ __ ] bring it home
dude
dude um i grew this beautiful plant
out of an avocado seed yeah that's true
i saw it
next time you're making guacamole i know
you're cooking more now
save the avocado seed and you like peel
it off and you put it with toothpicks
and a thing and and it grows a plant oh
cool and it doesn't even require soil or
anything you just put the roots in water
so i bought this like really pretty
vase thing for it and it just sits up
there and it's super pretty i'm just
stealing plants
the asian way dude my neighbor's just
taking them out of the ground getting
out of the ground just
sticking she's gonna die in like two
days a bunch of limp dead plants that
you
stole from someone else
[Applause]
wanting to find something to i didn't
plan on getting a cat i didn't want to
nurture anything but lately i'm like i
didn't want to
i didn't want him in her own body you
don't even drink water
how are you going to keep a plant
exactly i think i killed a cactus once
but you were in your 20s like once you
hit 30 you were like
cat yeah no i didn't even want the cat
yeah but yeah you got it
it happens to you dude yeah and you know
how [ __ ] up it is that during my
birthday month the people were like oh
can you update your amazon wishlist and
it was just like
i just want cat stuff okay it's so
stupid you immediately transformed
so dumb like i got the i got the the
scratching post that
tiffany oh yeah the cactus one i spent a
hundred and twenty something dollars on
a [ __ ]
scratching post yeah dumb dude why are
scratching posts so [ __ ] expensive
it's just wrong that's what i'm saying
but it was cute
you need to go to overstock
overstock.com i'm currently looking to
get those cat shelves that like i'm
thinking of that they jump
stupid yeah all the pet stuff is way
way overpriced because they know that
pet owners will do anything
kid stuff and pet stuff are so expensive
the capital is
capitalizing on our nurture jeans
exactly i'm just gonna throw like a
plastic bucket at him be like here play
with this
seriously they like it better they
probably will like i got a whole bunch
of toys but they like playing with a
starbucks plastic straw
kids are fun cats are dumb on that note
we all agree cats are dumb but they're
so cute
uh come over and play with my yes i'm
coming seven catsies
yeah and then also be sure to subscribe
and rate us on itunes we hope you liked
our ketchup chat
let us know in the comments what you've
been up to because like we've all been
living some
some crazy separate lives and we're
about to go on another break
true jess is going to texas yeah
go on our instagram dark shades
dark shades you don't know her mood
everything i have has an m on it now
i've got 137 m series labeled things all
over
a hat the jacket take a picture
yeah bye like our video give us five
stars on the thing
the thing that we need and then tell us
how you guys are doing in the comments
i love you peace out bye